et was on set of It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia
two days after 49 innocent people were
killed in Orlando using a semi-automatic
rifle it's a semi-automatic it has a
clip that you have to keep pulling the
trigger so in its like it not an
automatic rifle it's that's a lot of
shooting and you know it's a it's a gun
that we shouldn't have in our country
it's a gun that should be definitely you
know it's one thing to have a hunting
rifle or target pistol you know yes you
know but this gun is just made to you
know just put your people it's an awful
awful thing and we we just let it go you
know you and I you know everybody out
there we have to figure out a way to
stop and you know can't we do that it
means that sound like something that we
can't do anywhere it's the United States
for America will you do anything we want
I understand that it really is positive
I mean well talk about anything else I
mean I love doing the show thank you
very much for being interested but it's
like heartbreaking just nobody in the in
the government is reliable to get rid of
these guns the only people who can get
rid of the guns are people we can go
from marching the streets and say look
this can't be this this cannot be we
can't let this continue it's a shame
it's really a shame a shameful thing we
have like
you know that we allow this gun just get
it away we want to see that one again
this is ridiculous